antonio gates the native of Detroit we
have a listener Jeff in Detroit and he
said when you came on the show Antonio
I'm supposed to say what up doe how is
that is that the appropriate jargon for
Detroit what up doe okay normal I'm from
Detroit language if you don't know that
you're not from Detroit okay sure well
Jalen Rose always says that too so I
mean I'm straight out of Ohio so just
letting you know that I kind of plug and
play on some of these things I'm
supposed to know do you feel retired
yeah after yesterday and the genistein
was from us you know fellow teammates
and coaches yeah I felt like it was time
so like I needed time to reevaluate it
it took a while to get to this point you
normally when you get a word with tired
it's just like saying you can't do it
anymore for the long as I felt like I
had so I'm gonna change and then I got
to a point where you know as a course of
the season was going through I just said
yeah I think it's that time for me to
just go ahead and move on next chapter
of my life if I told you 20 years ago
you were gonna go to the Hall of Fame
what would you told me I wouldn't I
wouldn't believe it to be honest with
you not in the game of football you know
so my whole life was predicated around
the game of basketball so ironically
watching myself and hearing things and
all these jurors words about the game of
football
I still blows no way to this day but let
me know if I have this timeline correct
as a freshman you went to Michigan State
and you were gonna play for Nick Saban
but you were hoping to play basketball
for Tom Izzo and then Saban says you can
only play football so then you decide
that you still want to play basketball
you go
Eastern Michigan where you play for part
of his season and then you transfer to
Kent State is that right yes mmm what
was saving like high side
he was a genius at 17 years old didn't
really understand why he thought I was a
first-round pick in the game of football
that you could be a first-round pick
yeah he said I was the first home plate
and I want to say this I came on the
Browns he said you know he hit play
close to the ground I played he toasted
Browns and I'm saying you would NFL guys
are looking for you have been the
natural attributes at six forty to fifty
to sixty five the ability to move so I
was you know it caught me by blindside
as I was 17 years old I'm you know
that's what was my life for both
something that I I did and I was
talented at basketball was the majority
of my work was put into basketball so he
told me that I just didn't you know I'm
like man you know I'm gonna play
basketball
fast forward it yeah you know I want to
give him his credit he was at the Miami
Dolphins one year and I we D played us
in San Diego played the Chargers and
then once I had won eight catches for
like 130 yards and I think he came up to
me and again I said what'd you think
about that choice now who was the best
player basketball player you played
against in college I think Chris came in
I think that's the closest and he was
what Central Michigan with the central
mystery implies a year he's just the
name that most people would know Brandon
hunter who was at Ohio was really
talented at that time bring out of there
probably was better I mean nothing boss
they had a guy named Ron Smith
Oh No his career panned out monster had
the gun I'd looked at what the NBA Scout
said about they said you were a tweener
and at six four I could see where they
would say you were a tweener
if you if somebody said you were gonna
get drafted in the first round in the
NBA would you would you have gone to the
NBA instead of the NFL oh yeah yes okay
yeah well you think about all the you
know the sacrifices I had made up into
that point for the game of basketball I
mean that was basically my life and I
had put into one room but at the time
six four twinners wasn't you know
conducive to what the NBA needed at the
time and I think now you probably can
get away with it based on what you're
seeing go to state warrior do with
draymond Green and things that agent I
think now even the dollar play you know
you know guys like Steph Curry has
opened up doors for certain guards now
you'd normally have to be super athletic
and things of that nature to play point
guard spot so how about the big three
for you I can give Ice Cube a call and
you're turning 40 right so yes what
about the the three on three Lincoln the
players exact you a day okay
unfortunately the game of football
doesn't that you won't you know doing
how you want to do I have a couple of
charger questions before I say goodbye
is Philip Rivers coming back to the
Chargers you know question no not sure
are you sure you don't know yeah if I
said you could have Philip Rivers or Tom
Brady with the Chargers right now they
tell you okay so go say so
[Laughter]
so you know that's my guys only be my
guy I've been asked that question a lot
over the course of a couple of days yeah
what I've said what I will say is that
if whatever happens for the organization
you know I wish them the best because
that's like family me and syrup is
definitely found in me so I wish him the
best I know Tom Brady was you know
generous enough to come and join the
TARDIS I would definitely be one of his
biggest fans and supporters well
congrats on a great career and we
appreciate you joining in Santonio all
right what up no that's how we do it
it's how we do it I've never sounded
wider what up no for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]